check check check
people of the internet hello
and welcome to retrowreck into live a
very special edition as we react live
to the PlayStation showcase can everyone
hear me
can you all see me wait I got that
backwards didn't I
think I got it backwards
how's everybody doing welcome in welcome
in
it has been a little bit since we've
been live here on YouTube
thought we would
go ahead and uh try over here
try over here for today
Dylan already in the house jmax is
apparently GTA 6 trailer is on this I
don't think so
I don't think so
I feel like that's one of those rumors
that I mean like Rockstar doesn't need a
platform like this
it'd be amazing people would freak out
don't be wrong
but why you have to ask yourself why
would Rockstar
do something like that right
why would rockstar I mean they're big
enough to to just they could drop a
trailer they could do their own event
they could put out a tweet they could
put out a screenshot
and it's gonna get millions and millions
and millions and millions and millions
of attention so I'm gonna say no on that
one I'm gonna say no
see wolf pack how's it going thank you
for the thumbs up appreciate it yeah
guys if you're enjoying the video I mean
it's early
so maybe I shouldn't ask for the thumbs
up yet
but let me see how could we how could we
ask for the thumbs up now
and it still be a valid request
oh man if you were here we go here we go
if you're excited to see what Sony is
about to reveal
give the video a thumbs up and if you're
watching this later on the VOD if you
liked what they revealed and you're just
going back and watching this for our
reactions
give it a thumbs up there we go there we
go working it all in working it all in
Dylan how's it going dude
Joe Mack in the house as well uh what is
up jomack good to see you dude good to
see you Mike is checked and cam check
see you guys weren't expecting that were
you you weren't expecting just
us dropping right into the Stream
I'm trying to do that more often on
whenever we stream on YouTube because
otherwise you have to go back in and
edit out the intro
because if we do like the 10 minute
countdown people always I mean it's what
I would do right you're gonna skip ahead
so just to save you guys that extra step
I'm like I don't need a 10 minute
countdown so let's just go ahead and get
started anybody who's here early you
just get the benefit of this little
extra time to hang out and chat
oh I'm just glad everything's working
over here on YouTube because it's been a
little bit it's been a couple weeks
wubby oh my goodness wubby good to see
you welcome in Hylian Soldier how's it
going Ryan De La Cruz Ryan always
supporting no matter where we're at
no matter where we're at Ryan always out
here supporting
Harry Potter 101
dude we get the VIPs in the house today
man Harry Potter himself in the chat I
don't know why PlayStation's music is so
loud for me let me go ahead and switch
over to that screen guys
also oh wait you guys hold on let's turn
off the Elgato there we go also step
number one
hide their chat
let's go to theater mode here let's make
sure we're in the high oh wait they're
not streaming this at 4K
no way come on Sony give it the times
like it seems really loud to me so I'm
gonna turn it down for right now
what do you guys want to see
what are you guys okay I put out my wish
list on Twitter and this this is just
like me you know this is like pie in the
sky I'm not predicting this by any means
these are not realistic this is just for
me personally
ever since I played bloodborne
I've been waiting for a sequel Sony owns
that IP
how could they how are they not working
on a bloodborne sequel how how how are
they not paying from software whatever
they want
now I don't think that's happening
however there have been rumors for years
and years and years that blue point the
folks who did the Demon Souls remaster
there have been rumors that they are
also working
on a bloodboard remaster that feels a
little bit more plausible to me I would
even settle for that that's number two
on my list I'd be thrilled with that
honestly I didn't put it on here but if
they were even like hey bloodborne patch
update you can play it at 60fps on your
PS5 now like come on low hanging fruit
here
number three I set a new Sony handheld
so Tom Henderson of Insider gaming who
is very reliable has said Sony is coming
out with another handheld however it's
not going to be a dedicated handheld
it's going to be like a primarily a
Remote Play device
I mean I'm glad
it you know it's great but
that's just no no no no no no no
the switch has shown the path the steam
deck has shown the path for handheld
gaming
that is the path right there right there
you can't have this divide of games
anymore I think that's just that's just
done it's just gone
so it has to be it would have to be
something that in my ideal perfect world
like a Evita 2 or psb2 whatever they
want to call it that basically runs PS5
games just at my like a much lower
resolution and everything lower settings
and all that
number four this one I don't think is
has any chance of happening but a new
Infamous game I know sucker Punch's next
thing is probably going to be ghosts of
sushima 2 which I would be thrilled with
that as well
but I loved Infamous so much like that
Superhero they did such a great job and
then this one actually I think we're
gonna be getting a factions reveal so
basically The Last of Us multiplayer I
think that one is likely I think we're
gonna see that at least in some regard
today and then a wild card
well you guys think about that one huh
Hogwarts Legacy DLC now the only way I
could see this happening here
is if Sony had some other kind of
exclusivity deal for the DLC which
people would not be happy about
they would not be happy about it trust
me
so yeah there's my list let's hear from
you guys now uh anantha banana welcome
in Craig what is up Craig dude it's so
awesome to still see so many of the
the little badges over here even though
we haven't been streaming as much on
YouTube I have been trying to do more
behind the scenes members only Vlogs so
if you guys are not yet a member over
here on YouTube uh it's a little bit
different than on Twitch on Twitch it's
like you get a very clear you get
ad-free viewing when you're on when you
uh sub on Twitch here when you become a
YouTube member it's really just like you
supporting out of the goodness of your
heart honestly but I do try and give
some things back so you get like
discounted merch you get access to the
emotes here
and then
yeah I mean
it's it's just a little bit different in
how it works so one of the things that
I've been trying to do that I think is a
benefit of YouTube versus twitch is I
can give you guys like behind the scenes
videos so we've been doing more of those
more little behind the scenes things
that only members can see so if you're a
member here if you see that little icon
by your name you remember so you may
have some videos you can go and watch
that were just members only videos
all right I'm behind on chat as as per
usual
as per usual that always happens
Paula welcome in Paula good to see you
how's it going how's it going
I think so will be I think Spider-Man
for sure for sure for sure for sure I'm
expecting Spider-Man
goes music
I don't think it's expected goes music I
think it's uh it's whatever Sony is
playing here
in the countdown
um
PS5 Slim
PS5 Pro
PS5 slim would be kind of cool I'm not I
don't think they need a pro they're
making one it seems clear that they're
working on one but I just
I just don't think they need it man PS5
is like doing so well it's
it runs games at really good resolutions
and nice frame rates a lot of times even
better than the Xbox version sometimes
surprising people it's like wait Xbox is
technically more powerful why is this
happening but I mean I'm sure they're
they're gonna do it I'm sure so I'm just
like what what big benefit
would it offer I mean the fact that they
already have
4K and sometimes a lot of times even 60
FPS modes I guess when it's running at
they usually have to down scale it to do
something like super sampling so yeah I
mean maybe like I don't think we're
ready for 8K or anything like that yet
the themes on PS5 Craig says
zillion Jester Brazilian you better be
careful you bet if you play it in that
play test
that are your lips better be sealed they
better be sealed nature dweller welcome
man it starts in about 19 minutes
19 minutes is when it starts
so we got the little countdown well they
don't even have a countdown yet but they
got a little uh
graphic you're playing with music
[Music]
chuckle Brothers welcome in
Joe you like you a fan of Infamous 2
wait Infamous also
yeah it's like they did Infamous
and then they did inFAMOUS two and then
they did a Festival of Blood
which was which was a really good DLC
and then they did Second Son which
wasn't as well received second son is
still an absolute blast an absolute
blast and from a second son I didn't
feel like the story was as good I didn't
get as attached to the main character as
I did like Cole and the characters from
the other game
but um oh yeah there's there's my coal
statue he's down there
God of War is it time for you think God
of War DLC probably not yet right
probably not yet
I don't know it could it could be
Anna is here as well welcome in Anna
that's right Dylan you do get the
awesome emotes
you do get the awesome emotes
Bob Boba wait is that boba boba talks
welcome man dude thank you for being
here
oh I got you Dylan
that's funny
you just got a PS5 yeah they they
finally like over the past I'd say six
months or so they're finally more
readily available now
it took it a long time though didn't it
and I have no opinion on this just here
for the vibes Anna's like show me new
Star Wars game or something
there is a uh
rumors keep popping up of other Star
Wars games that are well some are
confirmed like in development
your entire self beat is all live
streams let's go
yeah almost went live on Twitch to do
this but I was like you know what we've
been streaming so much over there lately
let's hop over and do it on YouTube
today that way the other the great thing
about it being on YouTube is that
it will be here so it's like if anybody
wants to go back and watch it in the VOD
it's there for them
that's Jedi three
way too early for that Anna but there I
mean there could be Star Wars a Star
Wars something
Hollow Knight welcome in intermix Anton
how's it going dude so uh so pumped I
was able to catch your stream same here
man same here it's been a while since we
went live over here on YouTube If you
guys don't know we've been streaming a
lot over on Twitch we did a lot of
Hogwarts Legacy stuff over there
it's funny I tell the story the original
plan
we asked you guys the community
everybody wanted us to stream here on
YouTube which was the plan and then
Hogwarts Legacy did these uh it's like a
oh what do you really what do you call
it it's kind of like uh not really a
partnership but it's uh something that
is run through twitch called twitch
drops
and as a way to kind of like help
support the community we wanted to
stream over there to give people the
chance to get these drops and viewership
has just been really great while these
drops are going on which by the way if
you don't have your Merlin cloak yet
Avalanche tweeted today they are going
to have one more live stream over on
Twitch this is the only way you can get
the Merlin cloak you have to watch the
Avalanche live stream to get the Merlin
cloak
they're also doing drops for
Professor ronan's attire so if you're
not familiar with drops I know we have
some people who that they post on our
YouTube videos are like I don't do
twitch so if you don't do twitch drops
are basically something that you earn in
game for free just by watching streams
that have the drops enabled for Hogwarts
Legacy so we've been doing a lot of that
over there so that's where they did um
oh gosh it was like the urchin hat and
the first wave was not really that good
aside from the Merlin cloak this most
recent wave though has been pretty
pretty nice I really like Professor
ronan's gear
but who knows they may do more but uh
June 1st that is when Avalanche is going
to be going live over on Twitch and it
ends June 2nd so presumably
that could be the final chance at the
Merlin cloak if you don't have it yet
and if you don't I mean even if you
don't like twitch you can go make an
account it's free just like link it up
to your WB follow them for that day
watch however long you need to if you
really want it if you don't then who
cares don't worry about it
yeah it's uh let me check the Tweet here
I I tweeted it out too I retweeted it
uh Legacy live so here's their official
tweet returns June 1st at 9 00 a.m
Pacific Time featuring guests from
Avalanche audio story teams and more
make sure to tune in to get the Merlin's
cloak and the Ronin Cosmetics set before
the Redemption period for twitch drops
ins so the Redemption period ends the
next day
so who knows how long they're going to
be going I would say they'll try to do
at least a couple of hours since it
could potentially be the last
last chance
no Anna YouTube see that's that's
another benefit of uh there's like a lot
of things on Twitch that YouTube doesn't
have yet when it comes to live streaming
we still have alerts anytime like
there's a sub or
I think we have it turned on here for
donations too where it would read out
the donations and there's also one for
new members but yeah they don't have
like the sound alerts like we've been
doing over on Twitch as far as I know
I'm not seeing anybody have them enabled
it is starting in oh wait is that an old
question when does it start it starts in
about 13 minutes when the Showcase
starts here
appreciate it Dylan yes if you haven't
yet please hit the like button
for our favorite dad who loves games and
the stories they tell remake Kotor yes
so that's confirmed right it's just it
got they switched it to a new Dev
yeah Joe what were they I saw
I saw something earlier today there was
a comment somebody who would be in the
know on that game and it was basically
like
there's nothing happened
it didn't sound good
was my take from it
that's a good point Craig they could
absolutely do drops again so the first
time Hogwarts likes he did the twitch
drops they did it right when it launched
on PS5 PC series X and S
then they did another wave of drops with
the PS4 and Xbox One launch so
potentially we could get another one in
November that's a good point when the
switch version drops
man that that's that's a tough delay
isn't it for the switch folks
I've been meaning to it's probably not
something significant enough to make a
video but the one silver lining of it if
you guys remember has it been years ago
now for sure months ago potentially even
years ago
I made a video on
I hope this Hogwarts like Z rumor isn't
true about the switch version
I was thinking it was going to be a
cloud version of the game
however if you're looking for Silver
Lining and all this I do think that the
delay pretty much confirms that it is
not a cloud version if it was a cloud
version there'd be no reason to delay it
right
I mean they're delaying it to work it is
like seems like it is a native version
for the Nintendo switch
Jerry how's it going dude
haven't watched the live since yeah so
we haven't been as live much over here
on
on YouTube but we have been doing some
twitch lives and posting some Zelda
videos here if you guys are into Zelda
tears of the Kingdom you can check out
some of our recent videos on that
and we've got we've got a lot more
coming man there's one video
it's gonna be a big one I can't wait for
you guys to see it if you're if you're a
Wizarding World Fan you're gonna really
enjoy it I think it's just
I'm waiting on one more thing before I
can finish it off it's like a video that
is 95 done
and I one more thing has to happen so I
can make the final piece of it
so that one I'm really excited about
we're going to be doing more Zelda
videos I'm also working on a Hogwarts
video
that is uh kind of like a top ten
top 10 video on a certain element of
Hogwarts Legacy
what about the new PSP
are you saying like would I love to see
a new PSP is that is that a rumor is it
confirmed if it's the thing that Tom
Henderson was talking about
he said it was going to be like a Remote
Play device which doesn't excite me
a new actual dedicated Sony handheld
though
that was in my list of
things that I would
absolutely be over the moon about right
here a new Sony handheld that's not a
Remote Play device
my dreams only handheld would be like
just just make it so it runs
anything that's on PS5 just just run it
at a little resolution down scale
lower frame rate you know it's easy
right come on
I mean steam deck has showed that like
look look at what's possible
I think the steam deck has showed that
and the switch of course is had
incredible success but it's a very
underpowered system so a little bit of a
different story here
thanks Dylan for posting the link yeah
intermix check Dylan's link right there
it's the same username over there on
Twitch though retro raconteur
Craig getting the a Craig C I knew we we
set up those a while back nice to see
nightbot is still here nightbot's still
on the job good to know good to know
go ninja go
I didn't even see you there welcome in
Hollow Knight oh my gosh bro did you see
my list did you see my list look at this
look at this look at this
these are not predictions if you're just
joining in 100 not predictions these are
Pie in the Sky dream scenario
you guys would get an insane reaction
out of me here on the stream if they
happen that's what we're dealing with
yeah huge bloodborne fan though
huge bloodborne fan right here
oh you Stephen how's it going finally
got a new phone glad to be able to chat
well same here Steven good to see you
Sharma really love your videos I
appreciate it Sharma thank you guys
yeah it's certainly been you know we
knew there was going to be a drop off
after Hogwarts Legacy because we were
gonna have to Pivot to
to start covering something new so
those of you who have still been here
supporting it really does mean a lot I I
appreciate it more than you know
but don't worry we're not going anywhere
we're not going anywhere it cracks me up
man some of the comments we get from
people sometimes
it's like you guys think you have to get
a million views on every YouTube video
I'm like what
man we had a troll in twitch one day
they were real they were really like
they they were going in man
which I don't know what I've done to
like make anybody upset but they were
like dude you used to get
I can't remember what the exact wording
was it was like you used to get millions
of views now you barely get a thousand
and I was like
you talk I I used to get millions of
views what
I think I have two videos maybe three
now
over a million views
I'm like did I was I regularly getting
millions of views and didn't know about
it
Harry Potter how long oh not long we're
pretty much just streaming the Showcase
yeah we're we are primarily here for the
Showcase does anybody know how long it
is by the way I'm guessing about two
hours if it's much longer than that
I have to I have like a hard out at
about 6 30 Eastern I have to take my son
to baseball practice
when's the next spider-verse live stream
Oh you mean uh Miles Morales yeah I need
to do I need to finish that game I would
think I could finish that in probably
two or three more streams
oh the music the music's kind of
Shifting here isn't it
uh T-minus six minutes I'm gonna go
ahead and full screen this
make a handheld switch style yeah yeah
yeah you can connect to the TV
yeah nature dweller we do have some of
them set up not all of them because
there are certain differences between
YouTube and twitch but yeah some of the
commands do work here oh a red dead one
remaster isn't there rumors that that
was happening and got canceled
that Rockstar
decided to do something else I can't
remember
any PC ports you mean like PS5 to PC
I don't know I don't know if they've got
anything in store
they I mean they've committed to it so
it's definitely happening
just a matter of how long how long
they're gonna wait in between each one
so like what would the next big ones be
eventually you know Horizon's gonna come
over the second Horizon
Jesse coming
in for chat
Jesse thank you so much for that Super
Chat appreciate it my friend
I'm not sure why it's not letting me
see the amount of the super chat but you
know what the amount doesn't even matter
regardless of how much you
super chatted there and choose to
support I appreciate your support Jesse
how's you how's it doing YouTube full
time
it is
it's really fun of course but it is it's
very challenging which I was I was ready
for the challenge a lot of people think
that I thought like
I was gonna just like do Hogwarts Legacy
stuff and
the channel is going to keep going like
that no no what what Hogwarts Legacy did
is it bought me enough time to say
let's do this for a year
focusing on it full time and see what
see what we can do so we're in kind of
that transition stage right now which
oddly because Hogwarts Legacy on lash
and keeps getting delayed
we just now got the PS4 versions it
keeps kind of extending the life of
Hogwarts and Hogwarts is going to have
DLC uh you know I'm I'm predicting that
I feel pretty confident in that it's
just a matter of when
but yeah it's it's um
it's very challenging it's also very
exciting at the same time yeah
but yeah thank you so much for the Super
Chat
let's see what else what else do we have
here
it is actually confirmed from what I
know the project for the handheld is
codenamed cue light
dude I would be I well please just just
don't make it remote play only like it's
fine if Remote Play is is a focus
but Remote Play is not the way Sony it's
not the way
and I just saw this story about how
they're gonna be
like really going all in on cloud gaming
stuff and
uh I feel I'm starting to feel like the
old man you guys yelling at the kids to
get off my lawn
man like no
no I don't want to play through some
server that could go down that could lag
that that is dependent on like so many
things happening I just I just want to
put the game in my system even
downloading it is fine but I want to
have the game I want to have it
that's what frustrates me so much about
Nintendo too with all the old the old
stuff
I'm like Nintendo man
I love like they were doing so well with
like the Virtual Console stuff back with
the Wii first game it was just like a
trickle and then Wii U had a solid
Virtual Console too and then the switch
comes out and they're like
service service yes any way we can do
this service
so yeah it's probably me being the old
man like no I want to own the physical
copies and all that
Draco welcome in I didn't see you there
how's it going
unsung hero any Hogwarts Legacy news
honestly the biggest news right now is
the delay for switch and the twitch
drops coming to an end at the end of the
month June 1st basically it's gonna be
the last chance to get the Merlin cloak
Shane says remake of ape Escape I never
play like I I think I played a demo of
ape Escape but I never played the full
game
Joe 200 will get a Wizarding World MMO
I think I I actually think it's pretty
likely too not not today but
I think it's pretty likely man
and I'm there for it day one
retro can you blink twice about a
certain game test
oh dude
what game test would that be Dylan
I thought about Wolverine would be cool
but I think they're gonna Focus too much
on
I think they're gonna focus on the
Spider-Man stuff instead we don't have a
Spider-Man date yet like an official
date
any Wolverine teas would be awesome
though be awesome
April have to leave at five to head to
work hopefully won't miss much but I'll
stream stream it later that's right
April if anybody if you have to leave
that is the one major major benefit of
it being here on YouTube is it's gonna
be here for you guys waiting by the way
replay Squad if you're watching this
later let me know in the comments below
don't forget to give a thumbs up on the
video as we are now oh dude it's time it
is it is 4 P.M Eastern Time
which I'm pretty sure is the start time
of this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
time guys new Sly Cooper oh my gosh I'd
love that
hold on all right here rapid fire rapid
fire would love a new Infamous game
Ghost yeah I think the same thing too
uh Luna said any Wolverine we already
answered that one new Spyro
cloud gaming is bunk yeah I'm with you
I'm with ya
another Marvel game
ah not today
not today
JP raven fire what's up welcome in
Willie how's it going muestore what's up
mu store
lu3 wait you mean the last of us three
oh my gosh
I don't know if I'm ready for that
I think Joe and I feel Joe and I have
conversations on Twitter about the last
of us I think he and I feel the same way
about it part two anyway part one my
favorite game of all time part two I'm
just oh here we go here we go here we go
Ryan what's up dude welcome in
this program contains material content
that may not be suitable for all
audiences
oh it's low we gotta turn it up
my gosh the hype the hype is real
[Music]
we came ready today too you guys
PlayStation hat you can't see but the
shirts PlayStation as well blue shorts
oh yeah we're locked in
[Music]
cinematic trailer not actual gameplay
now I do love this just get just get
right into it man
Haven
I'm familiar with them
you want to know about us
seems like everyone does these days
it's simple
too much money
I was held by just a few people
and it's only getting worse
so
we decided to do something about it
let's go
[Music]
this looks like a multiplayer like one
of their uh
live service games
oh man hope this isn't copyrighted music
we'll find out soon enough
[Music]
fair games this reminds me of uh
Payday the Heist or something remember
that game developed by Haven fair games
is a trademark
that that is totally one of their online
multiplayer games that they've been
working on
their live service games
and I think it just said PC as well
you guys correct me if I'm wrong on that
I think it said it's coming to PC I was
looking at everyone
I'm Jim Ryan president and CEO of Sony
interactive entertainment I'm delighted
to be here today to introduce what's
next for PlayStation 5. we're now into
the third year of the life cycle of PS5
and we've been fortunate to have so many
fan favorite titles released on the
platform what's even more exciting is
that developers are just scratching the
surface of what's possible with the
gaming experiences that they create
right so we don't need a PS5 problems
into some of the most breathtaking and
imaginative content that's exactly right
Jim yes5 and Playstation VR2 and now
what you've all been waiting for
enjoy the show
PS5 slim I'm totally okay with that new
store totally okay with that that could
be cool super Earth
our home
our way of life but Freedom doesn't do
what
Fallout
look familiar some kind of weird things
like these are happening all over the
Galaxy right now and you could be next
that is unless you look at the motion
capture on the decision of your life the
face movement prove to yourself that you
have the strength and the courage to be
free
join the hell divers oh this was a game
on
Vida
I think they brought it to PC as well
this is a different one of course true
freedom
it's another online multiplayer game it
looks like
and secure the resources we need to
build a better tomorrow
the freedom to encounter fascinating
life forms and introduce them to our
sophisticated I'm intrigued by this
I was a big Destiny fan
represent the best
super Earth has
become part of an Elite peacekeeping
Force
and work together
to spread prosperity
Liberty and democracy
become part of something lost what they
call this one like if it's become a hero
a sequel or a legend become a helldiver
oh yeah sequel the result of
decapitation PS5 and PC 2023 there you
go
I'm intrigued by that
no don't you do not need VR to play that
[Music]
is the volume good on the PlayStation
side by the way guys
let me know if it's too loud or not loud
enough
EA Originals
speaking of Destiny it also looks like
another
[__] whoa okay I'm I am I am so here for
this
that enemy
night blades have established a
stronghold and kirken seems to think you
might not get me those are some very
large muscles
like very large
this is like Destiny meets uh Bioshock
or something
[Music]
what
these crazy boss fights too
haven't had enough yet we haven't given
them enough yet
another first spoken
your men killed my family
don't turn your back on me
you guys said a tad louder all right
we're going up
trying to
fight
a more wait Immortals of avium
who's working on that ascendant Studios
EA Originals
that could be cool that could be cool if
this is a
how are they not streaming this at 4K
anything with magic you're in
some of those abilities looked insane
it really did remind me of like Bioshock
and Destiny
another cinematic trailer are we gonna
actually see gameplay here
there's some gameplay
ghost Runner
blood will run 2023.
all right here's what I'm gonna do it is
sold out of my ear right now so I'm
gonna turn it back down here
and then we're gonna turn it up over
here for you guys what's your plan
knowing you have only 66 Days to Live
s game
all right
what
just run away
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
[Music]
I won't make any difference at the end
of the day
that looked very much like like a
certain
dude what is this
all right it's like ghost of tsushima
sakuro Devil May Cry
is this change you
sell them that looks so much like Dante
I think it does it not
oh dude this looks sick
[Music]
goodness
rise of ronin I'm not familiar with that
oh man yes this is gonna be
[Music]
oh and where I love secular
one last toast
and we're all done nah it's not Dante
I thought it for a second too though
[Music]
how do you know that Mew store am I
behind or something
[Music]
this looks insane dude
is not on his side
all we have to do is wait
yes
let's kill him with time
thank you
Phantom Blade
66 Days to Live it's a totally new IP
or I haven't I've never heard of phantom
Blake
coming to PS5
that okay I think that was the coolest
coolest looking one so far
[Music]
market like that
out of game
getting Journey vibes from this
[Music]
I called it dude
instantly it's like this looks like
Journey
Journey's one of my favorite games of
all time
I don't know if I would call it a game
though it's more like an experience
[Music]
just like
SSX meets Journey what
[Music]
hovering there
sword of the sea I would not have
guessed that name
he was like on Sand the whole time
yeah the music the music in their games
are always really good Anna
journey in particular has one of the
best soundtracks of any game I still to
this day will listen to some of the
some of the songs from that
a new world awaits you
full of dangers and Mysteries
signs and wonders yeah I would guess
it's probably way often again could
never have imagined
[Applause]
[Music]
think of the world we could build if we
believed in ourselves
if we truly believed in what it means to
be sentient
to face the universe without fear or
delusion
this isn't ringing any bells here the
vast cities full of life and Light
great Towers Rising Towards the Sky
iRobot the game
so much would be possible
[Music]
if we believe
if we still have faith
ah I didn't play the first game
do you guys play the first one how was
it or for any of you who did play it
whoa okay I'm loving the style already
[Music]
don't remember that game
oh that's a cool shot
[Music]
foreign
oh no I don't have a trailer that
the little one survived
really you're gonna do this to us in a
trailer
I want to play this game now
no
oh I knew the little one would survive
[Music]
look at these little whimpers in there
foreign
digital though
[Music]
right that was so depressing oh my
goodness this looks so good is that is
this actually in game
Cat Quest Pirates
Pirates of the Caribbean
all right now I'm not as excited but the
graphics do look incredible
Cat Quest
PS5 and PS4
it's like different gameplay Styles it
looks like
shifts into a couple different styles
there
mean material for sure oh dude hold on
this looks like something
I'm not gonna say it
Square Enix
uh oh
foreign
[Music]
don't think that's what they said there
it's definitely not Spider-Man
[Music]
Hey Jake thank you for the nine months
dude appreciate it
nine months as a member here over on
YouTube means a lot Jake
[Music]
what am I watching right now
this is from Square Enix
it looks like some sort of blend of
Splatoon
and fortnite
ballart meets Splatoon dude definitely
some Splatoon Vibes here
I never thought Nintendo would start a
trend with Splatoon but here we are
I don't think I'll play this
Jenny welcome in
ready for the foam Star Party
captions are so messed
the phone Star Party foam Stars
oh man I'm not feeling
I'm not feeling that
sorry if any of you guys are feeling it
hey it's all good welcome to the land of
Mojo for me
[Music]
our heroes protect the land from the
villainous sorcerer
[Music]
and even
Beyond
[Music]
there jock finds a whole new world to
explore with dangers surprises and
attractively furnished accommodation our
heroes must take back to Mario run
across the two Realms if they are to
save their beloved land from his
diabolical designs oh my gosh Dylan
Community night playing phone Stars I
don't think so
that would take a lot of uh gifteds for
that to happen
wait was it the Plucky Squire 2023 since
later
this year all right come on let's let's
ramp it up now
let's let's ramp it up Sony come on
[Music]
no way Minecraft is that the PlayStation
thank you
what is this
[Music]
I mean definitely Inspire oh tear down
I have not heard of that
definitely inspired by Minecraft of
course but
whoa the chat reactions are making me
feel like I should know what this is
[Music]
is it new or is it already like out on a
PC or something
I'm just now coming to PS5
[Music]
it's on PC gotcha
coming to PS5 there we go tuxedo labs
this year
Joe I said no way it's Minecraft
because Microsoft owns Minecraft at this
point that would be very bizarre
Murphy Aslan welcome
thought it was Minecraft explosions
oh no
okay that is
very close to an ant
you guys are afraid of spiders you might
want to look away
I'm a little bit afraid right now
Christy with the eight months Christy
thank you so much appreciate the eight
months
hope you're doing well today
hopefully it doesn't look too bad for
you guys it's so like you can definitely
tell it's
oh no no no no no no no no no no
oh my gosh what is this man
what is this
I can't look chat
the jump scares a jump scare is coming
what the heck
no way
Snake Eater dude so this was a big rumor
this was a big rumor
[Music]
I think it's a remake it's a remake of
Metal Gear Solid three Snake Eater
this was a big rumor
solid
triangle
what a three
oh man
is it exclusive though
okay coming to PS5 it doesn't say
exclusive though all right all right all
right
that's gonna be a big one
[Music]
wait wait wait Metal Gear Solid one
master collection oh my gosh hold on
that was that was three the first three
games right there coming to PS5
foreign
okay these captions are wrong guys I
think I'm just gonna turn them off
clearly they didn't preload the captions
so
[Music]
looks like they're putting the captions
on the screen when we when it's
something we need anyway
some sort of Survival game here
[Music]
wow
hello tears of the Kingdom breath of the
Wild
inspiration a little bit a little bit
[Music]
tower towers of
I didn't get the last part
a gosba
[Music]
what blind Marches On
these people live with a knife to their
throat dude who just said it who just
said Assassin's Creed we'd help you if
we could
Tom would love to see some Assassin's
Creed Mirage
Oh I thought that's what this was
[Music]
it is we who suffer Final Fantasy yeah
it did look like Assassin's Creed at
first
I hope so the audio is like this one is
much lower for me now
it's a mother Crystal s much quieter
sure it's quiet for you guys too
give us aside we'll decide our fights
another way
[Music]
I haven't played a Final Fantasy game in
so long guys
this one does look could you believe
what I'm about to do I'm definitely
intrigued
killed you do it by choice
you believe in me they believe in the
power of the dominant you Can't Blame a
language
we don't need your salvation we'll save
ourselves and we'll do it on our own
terms
to me you're free
who are we what are the dominance we are
but Mighty whoa oh God
enough of this I use my talents to my
advantage you would tell me there is
shame in that oh my gosh insane
I don't want to be a monster like
we
don't need a reason
[Music]
that comes out soon right
fate will fall
June yeah yeah yeah June 22nd
2023 there you go you pre-order the
collector's edition already new store
nice
all right let's see if the audio goes
back to how it was I'm gonna turn it
down just a little bit again for some
reason that one was really quiet
that trailer
I'm trapped here
in this nightmare
my right to escape
every word is a step forward
the darkness
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
it's right up your alley
the victim was one of their own
API special agent Robert Nightingale
oh my gosh only the rumors he was
chasing a writer my best friend loves
they were here one of my good friends
it's for us
the text is about us
we were all trapped in a horror story
The Horror Story wanted us dead
Keanu for a second I thought it was a
John Wick or something
oh man that
there's something I forget it
I see like that doesn't bother me at all
the huge snake though like it's not
right can't look
easy now
first things first what's your name
there it is Alan Wake to October 2023.
did the first one ever even come out
because originally it was exclusive on
Xbox right
did it ever come out on PS5
okay this is for sure Assassin's Creed
right
if this is not Assassin's Creed
welcome hidden one
they faked us out all right here we go
there was a remake that's right Craig
died
latest rumor I've been seeing is October
for this one
we need to find a way to get you inside
without being seen
you could bribe the guards to look the
other way I shall see what flavor best
suits me
[Music]
all right
I really hope the rumor is true that
they really focus and embrace the fear
or on stealth quite trying to Stillness
let's go
foreign
[Music]
that's his name right
they're watching
b-a-s-i-m I believe
October 12th there you go that was the
rumor
that was the rumor
[Music]
the glory Society
I love how we go from Assassin's Creed
to this
what's with all the cats man lots of
cats today
I didn't know it's two somebody in the
chat says maybe
Revenant Hill
rise together
coming to bs5 there you go
so I'm guessing this Show's gonna go two
hours but I don't know
maybe it's just one
it's 4 37 now and they've already showed
a lot of games
wait is this ginshin
[Music]
cool
similar style though
too many all together too many cats on
the internet
iridesh says
[Music]
Breakside grid on
what is it Hall night owl night's pumped
[Music]
I forgot the name there you go Grand
blue fantasy 2023 available worldwide
yeah you got it
Capcom
wait what did that say
is it time for
a new Street Fighter
I've also met my share of enemies
opponents I had to overcome
my journey knows no end I will continue
to do what I have always done
your story yards here
I said you were seeking strength despite
having no real need to do so
honestly I thought you were a complete
idiot
[Music]
Masters he was set up
any fighting game fans in the chat
chase after a monster like that I'm not
playing a Street Fighter game and
a very long time Smash Brothers is
always the only fighting game I ever
really got into Show Business plated
played Street Fighter lies a kid though
looking forward to Mortal Kombat like
Tekken Maria says
[Music]
when you go
like a game
this journey doesn't have a reality
[Music]
Street Fighter 6.
Street Fighter six
pre-order now and receive bonus content
I did see that rumor mu store yes
a Disney Smash Bros game which when you
think about all the stuff that Disney
owns now
would be incredible
you're one and only with Smash Bros
brawl
yeah I've played a lot of fighting games
but I've never really got into one
except smash
oh this looks like a metroidvania style
with absolutely gorgeous art
these 2D games man when they
when they have talented artists like
this
they just look incredible
oh yeah this is totally like a
metroidvania
ultros
hey have a good one nature dweller see
you later
[Music]
sounds good damio sounds good 2024 for
that one
all right man it's been solid so far but
I'm I'll be honest I'm not like blown
away yet
I mean they still haven't showed
Spider-Man I'm sure that's gonna look
great
probably gonna show factions at some
point but so far I mean nothing like my
jaw on the floor Snake Eater that's
gonna be
that's gonna be cool for sure but it's
you know it's a game we've already
played
remake of it
how about you guys anybody had like a
Blown Away moment yet
because the way people have been hyping
this up online
which is you know they still got they
still got time
[Music]
we've seen a lot like they've showed a
lot of games that look like
that sort of combat style today
okay that's cool we got mix
we got Mech ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
nah Anna the phone game just just not
doing it for me
not doing it
[Music]
wow I mean that this that one did show
Tower of fantasy quite a variety in
styles of gameplay I mean one minute
we're in the mechs and then
underwater all of a sudden
I feel like this is going to be
something Epic
fingers crossed Capcom
[Music]
Dragon's Dogma
Hey Joe that was getting that was
getting close to Your Dragon Age you
have been forgotten that you've
protected me from the dragon's Flames I
was getting very close
course that begs the question if he's a
man Mama then where might are true
for only the sovereign
[Music]
try not to talk much over it but those
those attacks looked very cool
[Music]
dragons
oh
[Music]
there's too many snakes today
that's Dragon's Dogma too
all right all right for another week of
career fulfilling I need to play the
first one though Joe sounds like I
should Joe sounds like I should know how
challenging it can be to find a place
where you feel that you truly belong and
to find a job that treats you mostly
with respect and only infrequently with
contempt
for that reason we are excited to inform
you that you did an adequate enough job
the first time around to have you back
this feels very familiar
this this vibe there were no other
applicants
so strap yourself in and get motivated
to an appropriate degree
because you ain't seen nothing oh I bet
that's what it is hollow Knight yes
that's
[Music]
oh my gosh
no way
on PS5
that is actually huge that game is
insanely popular
I've never played it and never even
heard of it I mean there that game is
crazy popular on YouTube though
[Music]
oh man I'm still not sold on VR
still not sold on VR yet
like I shouldn't say I'm not sold on it
like I just don't I don't feel the need
to buy one and own one in my house
all right
okay so they're saying over an hour is
what I'm seeing
looking on Twitter yeah seems like
they're saying over now
oh re4 VR
yeah Steven that's what I said I said
it's super popular on YouTube a few
years ago I had never I had never heard
of it
yeah I see it I see videos on it all the
time
[Music]
I don't watch them but I I see them
in development for PlayStation VR 2.
you're with me can't stand I feel they
ruin the game I don't know if I'm even
that strong on it give me Father Ryan I
just don't like it I don't want to own
one like and that's me as somebody who
loves Tech like really loves Tech
you see everything started two years ago
when I met someone
and ever since then it's like I see his
face everywhere and lately I've started
to develop some destructive tendencies
what do we have here bro what's a bit of
armless fun hello uglies oh my gosh
Wow since I met my new best friend I
guess I get a little overprotective
[Music]
okay very overprotected
I'd love to sit here all day and chew
your ear off I'll be right out boy
but as you know
time waits for no man
catch you later
who's a good boy remember this said new
IP if this is Arizona Sunshine Too looks
like today's
Duke Nukem VR yeah it definitely had
like those kind of vibes
nope nope still not persuaded on beat on
wanting to get anything to do with VR
I've tried me R multiple times it's like
the technology it's crazy it's it's cool
[Music]
but it's just not how I want to play
video games
like in my house for for hours on end
[Music]
Christian gamer welcome in it terrifies
you Christy have you tried it before
Crossfire Sears
these I don't see these selling like I
don't see these selling systems selling
psvrs
all you're afraid to
we'll just try something that's not like
try like beat saber
don't don't do anything that's
intentionally scary
he was one of ours
gone dark
I don't have to remind you what's at
stake here Christian gamer welcome in
it's going well
haven't personally haven't seen anything
but um wowed by yet we had a lot of
people in the chat excited by Dragon's
Dogma too
[Music]
there was a cool looking Samurai game
early on Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater
remake that was announced
probably my see What You're Made Of
that's probably my number one so far be
Metal Gear
[Music]
rather go to a haunted house and play a
war game or play a oh I'll pass on both
Craig actually I would I would
definitely prefer the game
I feel like this one's quiet again I
need you to focus
we have to adapt
back again like I could see this being a
cool VR game because of all these little
motions
you're basically like Jedi force Powers
Plus a gun
[Music]
they'll never break me
I don't know why it's not going away now
there it goes
all right come on let's end it with the
VR segment oh I was just talking about
beat saber
see if do you like
if you think you would like something
like this Christy I played this at
a uh where were we
it's like an art like you know like the
arcade game type places and it's it's
cool
but it's not
I don't I didn't feel the need to
I need to own this you find VR fun just
to hassle look out Luna see that's I
think that's exactly if I ever own one
myself
I feel like that's exactly how it would
be for me
plus like when you've got kids and a
family and other people living in your
house it's just weird to be like that
zoned out you know it's one thing to
have on headphones and be looking at a
TV but I can at least like see if my son
comes in the room or something but
you got that thing on and headphones
you're just I mean somebody could break
into your house you'd never know
all right are we done with the VR
segment now
[Music]
bungee
way
[Music]
do bungee game
cause it does not does not look like
destiny
[Music]
remember Sony bought bungee
[Applause]
what is this
oh I bet this is another one of their
online
that that kind of looks like
Destiny Marathon
game is not yet rated oh that's for sure
one of their online games
a weak trailer to be honest
that's just me
I mean it's like
they're going on the name
now that looks like Destiny hold up oh
No Just bungee
now this this is for sure Destiny okay I
don't even know where to begin
you've missed so much
I have I've kind of checked out I used
to love flame guys
I loved it so much
Vanquish nightmares a lot of changes
with Destiny 2 though I thought
alongside those who we once fought
against I lost the waist fell off the
wagon
I wish you could have been there
probably just their new expansion
yeah me too kiddo
but hey
I'm here now is this like Force ghost
Cade whatever the hell the hell here is
Force ghost Cade
final shape Destiny showcase 8 22 23
tune in to learn more I've been saying
for years they should have scrapped
Destiny 2 and just went straight to
Destiny 3.
but that's just me
Luna
I mean it's 456 now it's been one hour
we haven't seen Spider-Man a lot of
people were expecting Last of Us or the
uh the factions
Blastoise multiplayer game
[Music]
I mean you gotta show Spider-Man right
here we go Concord
[Music]
all right
coming 2024 to PS5 and PC
I feel like I need to do that dramatic
voice at the end of each of these
[Music]
all right I'm still not like Jaw on the
floor yet
I know me store that that
Spider-Man 2 was the The Gran Turismo
players in the world movie trailer place
in racing history
[Applause]
[Music]
Zodiacs it cracks me up
I can only get 20 so night Crystals at a
time
oh man I haven't played in a few days
I've been too busy but I need to get
I need to get work on getting a hundred
of those things
so I can upgrade my batteries
[Music]
based on based on a true story
only in theaters August
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna say no matter
how amazing Spider-Man looks thank you
for joining us today
before we get into our final game really
I have a few announcements to share a
PlayStation Innovation is our passion I
am and that applies to not just what
games you play but how you play them
later this year we will launch a
dedicated device that enables you to
stream any game from your PS5 console
using remote play over Wi-Fi internally
known as project Q it has an 8-inch HD
screen and all of the buttons and
features of the Dual sense wireless
controller it's just streaming
games must be installed on forward to
sharing more information in the near
future I'm also pleased to reveal our
first ever PlayStation earbuds that's an
L for me next Generation audio immersion
to PS4 that's an L for me they
simultaneously connect to Smart I'm so
sad new wireless technology will deliver
lossless audio with low latency that's
kind of cool action sound quality while
you're playing if you don't love uh like
the idea of having big heads on we hope
today's showcase demonstrates our
continued commitment to delivering
experience no there's one more game It's
gotta be Spider-Man I want to thank all
of you
for your unwavering support It's gotta
be Spider-Man right
dude the people who built this show up
oh my gosh man it's not okay that's
[Music]
Spider-Man
that is not Spider-Man
Wolverine Maybe
or factions
you grow slow in your old age okay
who
a fate you will not share
oh that's that's uh
Raven it is Spider-Man
oh my gosh I've been in your Shadow for
hours
since nothing
pathetic
Raven the Hunter
I asked for an equal
and this is what you find
sir
perhaps
a new hunting ground dude his character
model looks
very menacing
Black Cat Prowler wraith tombstone
Spider-Man
let the fires
the great hunt begins
oh come on you guys gotta show some
gameplay
come on
oh thank you
it's like if they end this without
showing any gameplay
thought it was in Spiderman anywhere it
was
uh oh no idea
symbiote
ins now
oh my gosh man
I can't wait to play with symbiote
crazy wants to hunt I'll give him one
he'll never forget
he's like you can tell he's changed his
voice up a lot too while he's affected
by the Symbiote
oh
oh my gosh man it's giving me some uh
who's that game on uh prototype
located at Harlem Fish Market all teams
converge lizards across the river
I'm not gonna make it in time
switch to miles
miles dude I wondered how they were
gonna handle that
dessert
I'm on it sounds like Craven's checking
off his
Office later
oh man I can't wait till they upload
this in 4k it's so compressed right now
probably doesn't look too bad for you
guys but on my end it's like
mom but yeah I'll boot up and see you
there
they got here fast
can't let them find Connors or he's done
for it
[Music]
oh that's cool spread out
it's been feeding perch takedown get
both of them right there
it's making me want to finish uh miles I
definitely have to before this goes out
[Music]
by the three tons of dead fish not well
where are you Connors
garage my lead to him
so we got Craven confirmed
Connors that's lizard
we're probably getting Venom I was tore
through this place
because
Pete's got the symbiote suit right now
three big time villains right there
release date yeah
some people were saying September
it feels a little early to me but
foreign
yes Craig we did see black cat on the
map
yep
oh no
drones picking up lizards Trail he's
still eating we can catch him wait
that's our drone
Yankee get behind me
dude
snakes again
just his skin
doesn't that mean he's kidding yes
lizards in this case
yeah
I know Luna I thought it was Green
Goblin too
amen
threads the building's swarming with
Hunters any sign of Connors uh yeah
Yankees tracking him hey Mr Parker
but the date is incomplete
okay I think I got a lot did you wait
you chill
that wasn't me you can already see where
this story is gonna go
I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
oh man he's huge
all right so who so they're hunting
lizard right now and it seems like can't
lose counters Harry's dying and he's the
only one who can help
he's trying to actually stop I got the
jet skis
save Connors
oh my gosh this is gonna look so good
watch out for those Thrones don't worry
they think I'm a friendly
it's just like some Uncharted for set
piece Vibes right now
which they had some in the first game
but
this game being PS5 only I'm sure is
gonna only be even more
[Music]
help the door vote right I've got the
metal murder bird
this little back and forth gameplay is
gonna be interesting in fact going after
Connors now this is on you
the boys and clouds that all you've got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how you looking
gunship won't quit I'm right behind you
we'll take it down together no time
that's always that angry Pete in the
chat
no no no Spider-Man it's good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
[Music]
miles is gonna have to step up big time
in this game
he's probably got to be the one to stop
him
lizard is huge
it's right behind you I know I know whoa
whoa faster
this is a long trailer in it they're
showing a lot
oh man I can't wait to watch this again
when they re-upload it
gunship can't get close enough but I
can't I'm one of them remember bro
that's it hey alley-oop on three punch
ah
one two three Ally
[Music]
see I just like tosses him he got away
from us
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
mine
you sure
it's got big teeth
so do I
oh man he's not normally like that
right
no
he's never like that
it's up to you miles it's up to you
foreign
put the date on it dude
fall 2023
all right I mean
like
Spider-Man look great
but that
I feel like people got their
expectations too high
which
never happens on the internet
ever happens
oh I'm so disappointed about that device
I'm so disappointed
remote play only dude it's probably
gonna be fairly
it won't be super expensive but like I
just
oh
so Spider-Man obviously looked great
Allen wake 2 is gonna be big
Final Fantasy that that Samurai game I
forgot the name of it that looked pretty
cool
see you later Joe have a good one hey
thanks for being here hanging out with
us appreciate it
Anton you think you'd give it a six out
of ten
oh yeah what would you guys rate it
would you guys rate this
I'm I'm kind of right there with you I
might even go lower
and again and I went in this with very
like I didn't read all the rumors and
everything I saw a lot of tweets about
stuff that people were thinking was
going to be shown and stuff like that
but
I feel like a lot of what they showed we
just
we already knew about I feel like people
were thinking there's going to be more
new stuff right
just a big big time L for me on the
Remote Play device though
I think that's it man I think that's it
[Music]
all right let's see what we got here
Luna says 5 out of 10. Anton said six
out of ten air Dash two out of ten Ryan
four out of ten
oh did they already upload the better
version yeah man
I'm still surprised they streamed at it
at 1080 but what if
Spider-Man saved it for you plus seeing
Mirage yeah I mean dude imagine if they
ended that without showing Spider-Man oh
my gosh
still no factions
I mean I know not everybody loves
multiplayer stuff but
Sony it went a long time without any
kind of show
and I'm I mean I'm like
I'm pretty close to Sony Fanboy but that
like that was not a in terms of like new
stuff they showed a lot of of games that
I'm sure are going to do well but
no like no jaw droppers for me yeah
nothing jaw dropping
we knew Spider-Man was gonna be was
gonna be good
we just wanted a date they didn't even
give us that
he gave us fall 2023
um you store said seven
four out of ten I'm not sure how to
pronounce your name say Satani
or out of 10 for Dragon's Dogma and
Metal Gear Solid don't care about spider
dude oh come on
Jesse said three Maria five out of ten
Harry Potter yes I agree that the
abilities definitely look good
Spider-Man was the only good thing
uh which one Ryan I probably missed it
regarding Horizon
I would probably give it without looking
at any other sort of reactions online
I mean I did have you guys to kind of
influence me but honestly I was kind of
in that five six range before you all
even started saying anything
I would say a five and that's for me as
someone who came in with with basically
no
expectations five is probably five feels
a little too harsh though
because they did show a lot of good
games they just weren't
my cup of tea
oh dude
5 out of 10 says we'll be two out of ten
but didn't have Spider-Man oh man if it
didn't have Spider-Man
[Music]
sheesh yeah I feel like Spider-Man at
least bumps it up to a solid a six for
me without Spider-Man like a three or
four
no quitted Champions about nah
nah no quidditch Champions info at this
event
it's doubtful that Sony probably isn't
gonna have anything to do with quidditch
Champions like they did with highlights
Legacy the only reason they had so much
stuff with Hogwarts legacies because
they
paid for an exclusivity deal
on the haunted house me quests and a few
other few other things
[Music]
don't get why Sony keeps making playable
movies instead of actual video games
[Music]
depends on which what you're talking
about with playable movies
like I think Spider-Man's great gosu
tsushima was great
um
Last of Us Gameplay wise was great I
don't consider those playable movies so
if that's what you're talking about I'd
have to
solid disagree there God of War I think
is great
[Music]
Spider-man always saving the day yeah
foreign
oh you asked uh Ryan's head like a
continuation of the Horizon forbidden
West games for PS4 PS5
[Music]
um forbidden West I haven't even played
that one yet Ryan I still need to play
it it is in my backlog to play
yeah but yeah I'm pretty sure they
already kind of accidentally announced
that Horizon 3 is happening which is not
a surprise at all given how well that
game's doing
they gave antonic crazy this is what
they gave us after not doing a Showcase
in Forever
that's where that's exactly where I met
Anton I thought they had more Heavy
Hitters they were sitting on X yes
exactly I think yeah that's probably why
expectations were probably higher
because it had been so long no E3 this
year you're thinking okay
Sony's about to bring the house down
right here and it was just
you know solid
your board games coming
here's a look at Spider-Man it looks
good
yeah I think you hit the nail on the
head right there though that's probably
why even me is somebody who hadn't let
expectations like build like crazy
that's probably why maybe subconsciously
I had a little bit higher expectations
and didn't realize it because it has
been a long time it's been a long time
for Golem does it come out does it come
out tomorrow new store
I haven't seen any reviews or anything
it looks kind of rough for a a little
bit
[Music]
but hopefully it turned out okay
oh yeah right Ryan I played the first
one
and I enjoyed it I just haven't had time
to play the play the most recent one
highly recommend uh oh wait what I think
about the new Assassin's Creed so I
thought it looked good
I haven't played an Assassin's Creed
game in a long time I've been told I
really need to play a couple of uh
I think it was the one in Egypt I've
been told I really need to play
I played the first Assassin's Creed I
played the second Assassin's Creed
and I believe I got the platinum trophy
in that one
then I kind of fell off a little bit I
came back for a Black Flag played a
little bit of Black Flag
played a little bit of the one where
oh the one where you're
like the a Native American right
that's that's not Black Flag though is
it
two is the best see that's good
yeah zodiac that was the one I played
the most
and then I haven't since then
Black Flag was the last one I I played
so that it's it's been a little bit
since I played but yeah I thought what
they showed looked cool I think my
disappointment always with Assassin's
Creed is they turned it into more of an
action franchise which is done clearly
done very very well for them a lot of
people love that series and it sold very
well
but from the very first
reveal of Assassin's Creed I was
thinking I I really wanted them to lean
more into the
stealth gameplay of like truly being an
assassin
rather than having these big fights
break out all the time you know
Assassin's Creed 3 is the Native
American okay so yeah I played a little
bit of that one too but I don't think I
don't think I beat that one and then I
did play some a Black Flag as well
you'd have been happy with a GTA
remastered remake alone see anything
that though new store they're just not
gonna announce it at an event like this
Rockstar's just not gonna do it they
have they have zero reason to
[Music]
unless like Sony and or Microsoft hold
off some crazy
exclusive for something big like that
although although in this new era like
this post E3 era of games
who knows what Rockstar will do
but Rockstar is big enough and GTA is
big enough they know they can drop a
trailer any hour any day any time of the
week
and not have to share with with anybody
I mean there there are a few games that
could drop a trailer
I'm trying to think like what would be
in that level of where
they would they would rise above
everything else
ta might
might be
I'm not like the biggest fan of GTA but
it might be like
I don't know like Half-Life 3 or
something like what what could surpass a
new GTA announcement
what what would be bigger than that in
gaming news
maybe not even for you personally just
like the broader gaming world
oh my gosh exactly I was so yeah I'm so
disappointed at that it that rumor keeps
popping up
how have they not done anything with
bloodborne how
it is it is actually mind-blowing
actually mind-blowing
you couldn't agree with more with you
couldn't agree more with your take oh my
yeah the stealth stuff
it just turned into something that I
wasn't what I was thinking it was going
to be as a series but yeah foreign
yeah
here's the kingdom oh like a trailer for
Zelda
see but the thing about Nintendo is it
it's Zelda's like first party only
and and you know what's crazy guys if
you go back and look at the history of
Zelda I mean it's sold well
it didn't start selling really well
until breath of the Wild
GTA
I need to look this up actually let's
look this up best selling games of all
time I'm pretty sure GTA is either
number one or number two
oh yeah Minecraft of course Minecraft's
gonna be number one
listen to this guys this is this is okay
this is actually insane for Minecraft
and GTA Minecraft is 200 if Wikipedia is
to be believed Minecraft
238 million
copy sold
now see they're on everything though so
that's that's a big help to them GTA 5.
180 million units sold
[Music]
wow there's actually a lot of surprising
stuff on this list for me
but video games have only gotten more
and more popular in recent years so
that's probably why we're seeing a lot
more recent stuff dude how the heck did
we fit sell so much
we fit if this is to be related on
Wikipedia it says Wii Fit sold
43.8 million copies
that's more than The Witcher 3 that's
more than Mario Kart Wii that's more
than Zelda breath of the wild that's
more than Smash Brothers ultimate
it's more than Call of Duty Modern
Warfare that's more than Skyrim what
Wii Sports is fourth on the list with
82.9 million sold but that's because it
was bundled with every Wii
pubg Battlegrounds the mobile game
Red Dead Redemption 2 is uh one two
three four five six seven eight on the
list
I had no idea Red Dead 2 was that high
human fall flat
a game I don't think I've ever heard of
we fit did not come with the Wii guys we
Sports came with the Wii comments are a
little bit delayed so I'm not sure what
you're referring to but yeah Wii Sports
came bundled in so
have I heard of Dragon's Dogma oh
absolutely yeah yeah I've heard of it
I may have even played a demo of
Dragon's Dogma always that game awards
event for big announcements true new
store but like if Sony was gonna do
something big like this was the moment
this was there like this was their event
this was the moment
I guess people need to exercise that
blows my mind that we fit
has sold that many
you're Wii came with a balance pad and
we fit
what
maybe later in the Wii's life they like
bundled it with that or something
[Music]
I had it I had it for a time too dude I
was in a Goodwill the other day and I
looked at their game section and you
know what they had in there a Wii Fit
balance board
they had a Wii Fit balance board in
there
cracked me up I didn't see a game with
it though
yeah this was the best-selling games of
all time
there are some surprises on here
Pokemon red green blue and yellow that's
no surprise
all right so here's your here's your top
ten here's your top ten number one
Minecraft 238 million copies sold number
two Grand Theft Auto 5 180 million then
it's a big drop off we go from 180
million to 100 million Tetris
[Music]
which that begs the question of how many
different versions of Tetris are they
including there
next another kind of big drop Wii Sports
82.9 million
then pubg Battlegrounds 75 million
okay so that's one two three four five
number six Mario Kart 8 Deluxe 62
million
after that the original Super Mario
Brothers at 58 million that might be the
most impressive one of all
because of how old that game is now that
of course also came bundled in so
Nintendo kind of has that Advantage when
they bundle games in right
all right so let's see that's three four
five six number seven Red Dead
Redemption 2 53 million number eight
Pokemon red green blue yellow see that's
kind of not fair when they include them
all like that but
Terraria is next on the list 44.5
million
and then rounding out the top ten let's
see that's three four five six seven
eight nine oh no Terraria is number ten
and then it was Wii Fit Plus okay wait
then 1989 Tetris is after that
so Tetris appears on the list twice
so apparently there was a 2006 version
of Tetris
that has sold 100 million copies
oh it's um it's the mobile Tetris
it's the mobile Tetris okay so the
original the 1989 version of Tetris has
sold 43 million copies
and then after that okay this is the
last one I promised Animal Crossing New
Horizons 42 million
copy sold and that's a more recent game
that's crazy
another showcase later this year I don't
I don't think so Anton
I mean who knows like now that we're in
this we're in this we like there's no E3
anymore
PlayStation hadn't done one in a while
I mean I guess they might do another one
like around November sometime
Spider-Man the uh the Samurai game
Assassin's Creed Mirage that's pretty
much it
no Dylan I'm not pre-ordering foam Stars
the Solitaire count on every PC in the
90s
too funny
all right man well hey I appreciate you
guys all hanging out sorry it didn't uh
turn out as great as we were hoping
there but really appreciate the support
and everybody hanging out and chatting
we'll do this again man anytime there's
Live Events like this also I clearly
need to finish my Spider-Man play
through or my Miles Morales playthrough
in preparation for the next Spider-Man
game so keep an eye out for that we'll
make sure to stream that live here when
we do since we already started it here
on YouTube but yeah man if you guys
aren't subscribed to the channel yet
here make sure you subscribe before you
go
as always
thank you all so much for watching guys
and I will talk to you again soon later